hey guys how are you so I'm about to hop
on a flight here in actually I need to
leave in like 10 minutes but the Apple
pencils must be delivered today and it
was not it still might be like my iPad
wasn't delivered in two like 8 p.m. the
whole keyboard does not ship I don't
think until another few weeks so a lot
of people haven't really enjoying the
Logitech version that was actually the
only thing that's available I got this
today that I got my iPad and I still
haven't unboxed it yet so I'm gonna need
this for for the flight because if you
guys haven't used the iPad pro it's kind
of hard to type on its massive I'll be
there trying to type I'm just like so
let's take a peek at this and see what
it's like
oh I waited all this time to open this
and all I had to do is lift the tab
anyway this is it making the unboxing is
done is that it this is it this is it it
says it uses a smart connect to charge
you never have to actually charge it
what I will be curious to see is if how
much does that kill your iPad battery
life it's actually about a funny because
when I bought this I was like oh does
this use a smart connect he's like no it
doesn't so oh okay
that's weird it says so on the box so
what do I know I can't read stick it in
like so okay it's close it's heavy this
is heavier than my laptop it feels
exactly the same as my laptop
heavy so let's hook you in SmartConnect
Wow a keyboard lights up and stuff look
how nice that looks
this doesn't feel very secure though
look forward to doing a side-by-side
comparison of this to the other actual
Apple keyboard and oh my god I just went
like this to use the trackpad guess what
there's not there's not a track that can
I use Apple oh my gosh yes the shortcuts
work so shortcuts work hello I am
writing notes okay let's see if we can
draw something don't actually have my
pencil yet can you even see that there
you go that's a little better
sees a little darker of a color let's
maybe switch to the highlighter so this
is just in the Apple notes it's really
not a special program nothing crazy
super basic about these cones you've got
here's a roller which i think is kind of
cool you know just in case
you know you need to you need to do some
measurements did this actually can we
just erase we can look at that just you
racing going undo there's multiple undos
everybody wonder how many there are that
was like three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen to thirty thirty-two okay
there's a lot of undos you can do a lot
of undoing I'll take a photo let's flip
it okay that's a good picture really my
best work I am writing a note can I draw
on this nope
logitech option for the iPad pro I think
it's a little bit heavy but I'm not sure
what the weight comparison will be to
the actual Apple one and I guess can be
a really interesting to see who really
gravitates towards the iPad pro I think
it's great being an absolute apple
fanatic but I think for everyday use for
some people it might not be the way to
go I still think that the 13-inch
MacBook Pro for anybody that's looking
to sort of just do email straight up you
can do pretty much everything and you
can still sort of edit video and it has
a full operating system I still can't do
a lot of things on iOS because you can't
upload YouTube thumbnails and that's one
of the main things that I end up having
to do on the go and I can't do that in
iOS and it's super frustrating I mean
nowadays my phone is so massive I end up
just watching shows and stuff like that
and then so I look forward to doing a
full review of the Apple pencil which
hopefully will be here soon so I'll show
you guys that and also an update I am
extremely excited to announce that my
Apple watch survived the wash I am so
happy that I didn't have my steel band
on it because definitely would have been
destroyed and probably bent so what I
ended up doing was I plugged it into the
wall and left it charged overnight and
it ended up working so I'm not sure if
my laptop wasn't putting out enough
power or what I'm not sure either way
it's uh it's working so here we are I'm
really excited about it and just as I
said that I got a low power warning
thank you guys for watching if you're
new here make sure you subscribe I love
Apple stuff I'm always yapping about it
and I think that's it uh yeah see the
next video my watch I just got back
we're gonna do a little test and see if
it happens to work cross your fingers
I'm gonna put you guys on top of this
coffee